الشخير شائع جدًا
اعتمادًا على ما تقرأه في أي مكان، هناك ما بين
40 إلى 60 شخصًا يشخرون في
أي وقت،
الشخير هو ببساطة مجرد اهتزاز
للأنسجة سواء كان ذلك في الأنف
أو الجزء الخلفي من الحلق، لذلك يوجد في الأنف
طيات جلدية صغيرة تسمى
المحارات، وعندما يعاني شخص ما من
الحساسية على سبيل المثال، يمكن أن تلتهب تلك التوربينات
بشدة مع مرور الهواء من
خلالها، مما قد يتسبب في
اهتزاز الأنسجة، حيث يكون الشخير
في الجزء الخلفي من الحلق حيث لدينا
اللهاة التي  هو شيء صغير
معلق في الجزء الخلفي من الحلق وهو
الحنك الرخو من أنسجة اللوزتين وهو
نوع من الجزء الخلفي من سقف
الفم يمكن لأي شخص أن يجعل تلك الأنسجة
تهتز ويمكن أن يسبب الشخير أيضًا،
لذلك يكون إما من الممر الأنفي أو
في  الجزء الخلفي من الحلق
هناك بالتأكيد أسباب وراثية لحجم
اللسان حيث يجلس الفك ومدى
ارتفاع اللسان مقارنة
بسقف الفم إذا كان هناك
أنسجة أخرى قد تضغط على
مجرى الهواء
فهناك أسباب مثل الكحول
يمكن للكحول الصحيح أن يجعل  الأنسجة في
مجرى الهواء أكثر استرخاءً ويمكن أن يؤدي ذلك إلى
زيادة مرونة الوزن، ومن المؤكد أن ذلك
يلعب دورًا صحيحًا، فكلما زاد عدد الأنسجة الدهنية الموجودة
حول الرقبة، كلما زاد
الضغط على مجرى الهواء
إذا قضى الأشخاص الكثير من الوقت في
ظهورهم يمكن أن يسبب الشخير لأن
نوع الأنسجة الذي يسقط إلى الخلف إلى الجزء
الخلفي من الحلق
[موسيقى] من
المرجح
أن يحدث الشخير مع تقدمنا ​​في السن، وذلك لأنه مع
تقدمنا ​​في السن تصبح عضلاتنا أكثر
استرخاءً،
لذا فإن الشخير بحد ذاته حقًا  لا يمثل
مشكلة كبيرة ولكن الشخير يمكن أن يكون
ممثلًا لانقطاع التنفس أثناء النوم، لذلك إذا كنت
تعتقد أن هذا هو مجرى الهواء الطبيعي،
فهنا يحدث الشخير حيث يكون
ضيقًا، ثم هنا انقطاع التنفس أثناء النوم،
لذا فإن مجرى الهواء مغلق تمامًا،
وهذا انتهى  الوقت ليس جيدًا
لشخص ما